en un experimento dirigido a estudiar el
efecto de la publicidad sobre la
conducta alimentaria en niños
un grupo de 500 niños de 7 a 11 años de
edad se asignaron aleatoriamente a dos
grupos distintos después de la
asignación cada niño vio una caricatura
en un cuarto separado en donde había un
recipiente grande con galletas de
animalitos la caricatura incluyó dos
cortes comerciales el primer grupo dio
comerciales de comida sobre todo botanas
mientras que el segundo grupo dio
comerciales que no eran de comida juegos
y productos de entretenimiento una vez
que el niño terminó de ver la caricatura
los conductores del experimento pesado
en el recipiente de galletas para medir
cuántos gramos de galletas se comió el
niño ellos se encontraron que la media
de la cantidad de galletas comida por
los niños querían los comerciales de
comida es 10 gramos mayor que la media y
la cantidad de galletas comida por los
niños que dieron comerciales que no eran
de comida veamos qué es lo que nos han
descrito hasta aquí seleccionaron 500
niños seleccionaron 500 niños y los
asignaron al azar a dos grupos un grupo
aquí y otro grupo acá digamos que este
es el primer grupo el primer grupo
comerciales de comida así es que este es
el grupo número uno este grupo vio
comerciales de comida y podemos llamarle
el grupo de tratamiento queremos ver
cuál es el efecto de ver comerciales de
comida y también nos dicen el segundo
grupo vio comerciales que no eran de
comida este es el grupo de control este
es el grupo número 2 yo comerciales que
no eran de comida así es que este es el
grupo que vamos a llamar de control y
una vez que el niño terminó de ver la
caricatura pesaron los recipientes para
determinar la cantidad de galletas que
había consumido cada niño obtuvieron las
medias para cada uno de los grupos y
determinaron que la media para este
grupo el grupo de tratamiento era 10
gramos mayor que la media de este grupo
de aquí el grupo de control por lo cual
simplemente con esa información
bueno pudiéramos pensar que algo está
pasando aquí quizá el tratamiento de ver
comerciales de comida está haciendo que
los niños consuman más galletas de
animalitos pero la pregunta que siempre
hay que hacerse aquí es hay alguna
posibilidad de que estos resultados se
hayan debido simplemente al azar que
aunque tú no hubieras hecho a este grupo
comerciales de comida que hubieras
instruido a los niños aleatoriamente y
haber hecho a los dos grupos ver el
mismo tipo de comerciales aún así cuál
es la probabilidad que únicamente debido
al azar se tenga la media de un grupo
evidentemente mayor a la media del otro
como sucedió en este experimento donde
los niños aparentemente comieron en
promedio 10 gramos más pero entonces
como calculamos la probabilidad de que
esto de que los 10 gramos que se
comieron más en promedio este grupo de
aquí haya sido debido únicamente al asad
bien la manera de hacerlo es como lo
hicieron ellos aquí usando un simulador
ellos se asignaron aleatoriamente le
asignaron aleatoriamente los resultados
en dos nuevos grupos y midieron las
diferencias entre las medias de los
nuevos grupos ellos repitieron la
simulación 150 veces y graficaron las
diferencias resultantes como se muestra
abajo lo que hicieron fue esto tenían
500 niños
digamos vamos a ponerlos aquí 1 2 3
así hasta llegar a 500 y para cada uno
de estos niños los investigadores
pensaron la cantidad de galletas que el
niño se había comido y pudiera hacer que
el niño 1 comió dos gramos el niño dos
comió cuatro gramos el niño tres no se
comió 12 gramos y así hasta el niño 500
que quizás no comió conmigo 0 gramos y
lo que sabemos es que quizás la primera
vez desde el niño 1 hasta el niño 250
suponemos que la primera mitad de los
niños está en el grupo de tratamiento
cuando lo ponemos así dado por supuesto
que esto fue debido a una asignación
aleatoria y por lo tanto entonces este
segundo grupo que formamos aquí en el
grupo de control así lo que continúan
haciendo es tomar los mismos resultados
y reasignar los aleatoriamente pudiera
hacer que en la siguiente asignación
este resultado ahora va al grupo 2
también este resultado pudiera ser que
vaya al grupo 2 y así y este resultado
se quedará en el grupo dos mientras que
quizá éste se queda
grupo 1 y este ahora iba al grupo 1 de
tal manera que ahora ya se mezclaron
totalmente los resultados resulta
totalmente aleatorio si un resultado se
ubica en el grupo de tratamiento o en el
grupo de control se calcula la media del
nuevo grupo número 1 y la media del
nuevo grupo número 2 se obtiene una
diferencia entre esas medias y aquí nos
están mostrando cuál es la distribución
de esa diferencia de medias y aquí
podemos ver que cuando lo hicieron de
esta manera cuando reasignado los
resultados a dos grupos distintos se
encontraron una gran cantidad de
asignaciones donde no había una
diferencia entre las medias así es que
de las 150 veces que repitieron la
simulación que hemos descrito aquí
tenemos que 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 aquí tengo pruebas para calcular
esto a ver 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
que ya no se está muy pequeño esto en mi
vista ya no es la misma creo que ya ya
estoy envejeciendo pero parece que hay
del orden de 1920 pongamos 20 casos
donde no hubo una dice
entre las medias de los grupos cuando se
reasignaron aleatoriamente los
resultados entre esos grupos de tal
manera que cuando vemos esto si
simplemente se asignan aleatoriamente
los resultados a dos grupos la
probabilidad o más bien aquellos casos
donde se presentan diferencias de 10
gramos son casos poco probables veamos
esto aquí nos dicen que son las
diferencias entre las medias de los
nuevos grupos pero no está claro si la
diferencia entre el grupo 1 - el grupo 2
o la diferencia del grupo 2 - el grupo 1
sin embargo aunque tomáramos ambos casos
la situación donde encuentras una
diferencia entre las medias de 10 gramos
es de tan sólo 2 entre 150 veces es
decir cuando lo haces aleatoriamente
cuando asignas aleatoriamente los
resultados a estos dos grupos la
probabilidad de encontrar una diferencia
entre las medias tan grande una
diferencia de 10 es de tan solo 2 entre
150 aquí hay un total de 150 puntos es
del orden del 2% no de hecho es menos
del 2 por ciento está entre 1 y 2% y si
supiéramos precisamente cuál es la
situación
aquí digamos que es la media del grupo 1
menos la media del grupo 2 indicándonos
cuanto más se comió entonces estaríamos
en este caso donde la probabilidad es de
tan solo 1 entre 150 es decir ocurre
menos del 1 por ciento de veces ocurre
una vez en 150 casos al ver esto y como
esto se hizo de manera aleatoria podemos
establecer que la probabilidad de
obtener los resultados que se tienen es
de menos de 1% así es que para mí y para
la mayoría de los estadísticos eso nos
dice que el resultado el experimento fue
significativo que la probabilidad de
obtener los resultados que se obtuvieron
la media de los niños que dieron
comerciales de comida es 10 gramos mayor
que la media de los niños que no vieron
comerciales de comida si de manera
aleatoria pones a 500 niños en dos
grupos distintos basándonos en las
simulaciones que se hicieron encontramos
que en tan solo una de esas 250 veces se
obtuvo una diferencia de 10 gramos por
lo que parece muy improbable que esto
haya sido así debido al azar si esto
fuera un evento meramente aleatorio esto
pasaría una de cada 250 veces por lo que
el hecho de que éste haya sido
lo que presentó tu experimento te da la
confianza para afirmar que tu
experimento es significativo en la
mayoría de los estudios en la mayoría de
los experimentos el umbral que se
considera la probabilidad para que algo
sea significativo es del 5% si la
probabilidad de que algo ocurra por azar
es menor al 5% entonces el significativo
este es menos del 1% así es que
definitivamente este experimento es
significativo